it's a good morning everybody so this is
ramus Adhikari and I'm from Humble State
University and I have a PhD in finance
so this year I chose to submit this talk
to this conference thinking that I can
teach some finance to this computer and
software engineers I hope that this is
going to be interesting for you guys my
my goal is to so the use of Mathematica
or Wolfram language in the investment
analysis so those of you guys who are
very well-versed in programming how can
you think of choosing investment field
as your professional career or
consulting for those kind of things so
what I would like to do here is mostly I
would like to talk and so the
application of this Wolfram language for
analysis of investment that's what I'm
trying to do here so so I have a broad
outline here so the cover is very wide
here
so I teach finance courses and what I
did for this talk was I pull major
computational part of my course and put
this all together so this is a kind of
summary of three courses I teach but at
the undergraduate level and the graduate
level so I will very quick because each
topic needs a very detailed discussion
but since the goal is just to introduce
you the new field to you guys so I would
be very brief and I will be showing just
the application part so why I choose
this wolfram and I think we all have our
own story but for me I went through
different programming languages in a way
when I came to this well from the first
point made very good sense to me and
actually I am writing a book based on
what I have here so that book has
built-in text code and everything I do
in that text is collecting data from
online sources and
using result within the text so
traditionally we have a text and then we
need to do something you have to
download the data and put on your
computer and upload it and do your lysis
right so for this the kind of text that
I have envisioned that I'm working for
is mostly it goes and pulls the data
from different sources and then computes
and does the analysis that you said to
do and produce the result so then you
can use for your benefit so the next
what I'm going to do is I will go over
broad set of applications that I think
and again we all are the victims of our
own knowledge limitations if if I says
something that doesn't make sense to you
please excuse me again
the choice of the application is purely
based on my own experience but I think
Wolfram can go way beyou and then what I
have presented here so the first one
first thing first would be to to have to
access the data so there are different
ways you can get the data on this and if
you have a professional version I think
they have integrated did I'm like did I
import from Bloomberg and Reuters but
mostly this is free free free kind of
like data sources so first what I see or
what I so here is how can you get data
for your data analysis and visualization
so I have few examples here so one would
be simply using the built-in functions
to download company fundamental data and
then plot this and make our databases so
that would be the first application
because without data so we can go
nowhere so I have here sown some
examples by the way these all are the
functions that I wrote based on the
features that I have available in the
Mathematica so so these are all the
functions you know what I'm going to do
when I'm done actually I will upload all
functions that I have written and make
available to the user so that's the goal
so so here I have the data on Apple
stock and I have return on asset return
on equity and revenue growth the first
one and then the second one what I would
like to do is I here the performance of
different companies and see how they
these guys do so what what is the beauty
of this Wolfram language or the world
the book that I'm talking about is next
time when people would like to reproduce
the result all they have to go is change
the ticker symbol and then the change
date and read on the program and then it
just gives you the result so so that's
that's that's the beauty of I think
building software system that can go and
pull the data from online sources and
produce the result and here's a that are
you tribal from cuando cuando is I think
building a huge data library and then
you can pull the data from quantal and
do all kind of analysis then I also have
here data from Federal Reserve so if you
if you know what kind of data you need
you just need the ticker symbol so all
you have to do is put the ticker symbol
on the top and then change the date and
then you plot it and then it gives you
and and also what we can do is I have
done this one leaf or one stock but you
can download the huge amount of data and
make the database of stocks or anything
that you're interested and then using
the SQL query language you can do all
kind of analysis so that's why the first
the first focus of this wolfram is
mostly how to retype data so that's the
one thing the second that I would like
to talk very briefly and I think for
many of you this might seem very foreign
valuation business valuation so often
time when we think of investment valuing
the financial asset is the first thing
that we should
understand otherwise you don't know what
you are doing right so therefore these
examples focus on how can you value
financial assets but this is purely one
example but wolfram can be used in a
wide varieties of valuation areas from
startup valuation to the valuation of
well-established company into valuation
of a stock or valuation of bonds and all
kinds of things so and not only on the
top of that we can also use this Wolfram
language for capital budgeting investing
when businesses make huge investment how
can we use Wolfram language in order to
make this capital investment decision so
this is the second area of application
of for from finance the third area okay
I would like to go and talk about the
performance analysis of stocks if it is
individual stock how would you do some
analysis so here I have written
functions all you have to do is just
change the ticker symbol that you would
like to analyze and then change the date
and then look at the performance and I
have different kind of graphs price over
time normalized price over time and I
think we even don't have time to go over
each of this graph I was just so the
broad application that I have chosen
here and then we do have some
descriptive statistics that we can
compute in a one-line code and if you
are looking at multiple stocks then you
can put those multiple stocks and and
then make a craf and this graph is one
is I have the normalized price basically
that tells you if you had invested $1
back in 2000 on each of these stock how
much would that be today that kind of
things
that's a normalized graph and then and
not next with the cumulative return and
I can also calculate performance of
these this talks so why I think Wolfram
is very good if if anybody would like to
understand about
finance one has to understand psychology
one has to understand economics theory
and one has to understand also the
finance theory but that's not enough to
learn finance one has to know
mathematical statistical theory as well
as computer programming so Mathematica
provides some tool that can help you on
the mathematics and statistic in the
programming side of investment analysis
that's why I think you know this is one
line of code and like a lot of mazes
that have reported can be computed with
building functions and some other
performance analysis you can combine
some other built in function and then
you can compute them so therefore like
this Wolfram language becomes very
powerful when it comes to performance
analysis of stocks so the next I would
like to show you the factor models which
means this is a this is the emerging
literature of people talking about this
factor model i factor modeling and
factor investing which basically means
we all want to invest in the stock but
we don't know where to invest right so
the factor model tries to explain what
factors should you look at about the
company if you would like to invest and
make money over time so what I have done
here is that there are different kinds
of factor models but one of them one of
the most popular factor model is five
factor models so what I do here is all
these factor data is available online so
you go and pull those factor data and
then you have the stock price you can
pull from your financial data sources
and then merge these two and then run a
regression and give you the result so
this is just an example but if you have
let's say if you have a 500 stocks then
you can run 500 all kinds of regressions
and then that that gives you the factor
loadings and
these factor loadings has its own
meaning and if you know how to interpret
that meaning then you can build all kind
of portfolio that that you are
interested in based on those factors so
this is another application of welcome
language that that I am aware of and the
third I think another one is you know
how we can evaluate the performance of
investment
it could be mostly the performance of
portfolio if you have invested in a
multiple stocks and you have a portfolio
what meters are you going to use to
evaluate the performance of your
portfolio so so this one line of code
can compute all these measures they are
very standard measures they are used to
evaluate the performance of portfolios
so anybody new to this field can come
and change the ticker symbol these are
the mutual fund that I am looking at
which mutual funds are doing how so
anybody interested in what they have to
do is simply change the ticker symbol
and I'm comparing the performance of
this three mutual similar mutual funds
with this SP why SP why is the the ETF
that tracks the S&P 500 so that's a
little another area of again as I said
this is very comprehensive we don't have
time what each of these numbers means
but I will make this slide available and
then some interpretation of the numbers
later so the another area of is
technical analysis when it comes to
technical assets Wolfram language is
very well versed it has a lot of
function but one of the things that I'm
interest is pattern recognition you know
the stock movement and how we can find
the overbought and oversold looking at
the historical price so so the pattern
recognition and actually I think we all
are familiar that wolfram is very good
on pattern hallucination but I haven't
seen anybody done that work using
Wolfram language and I think there's a
field and what we can work on factor
pattern
a nation on the stock prices using all
firm language and I think there can be
some online tool we can develop out a
bit that's another area where we can
think of using Wolfram language here I
was trying to find out the buying and
selling signal on this rock with stock
when I was looking at this data last
time
another area would be borne and
derivatives bond market analysis and
everybody product we can use there too
so here I have manipulated and we can
change the different parameters of the
options and change how the price of call
and put with chains and binomial model
some of you may be familiar because this
is very popular model but one other
thing that I am interested here is I
have written a function what it does is
it pulls the data of a real company and
then computes its call input price and
then gives you the theoretical value
that's it's important and you can always
compare the performance of the any stock
in a theoretical value versus what the
value observed and if there is some
discrepancy why is that so that's the
another area of Finance that I have
looked at another one would be linear
programming I think again this is a
giant problem I converted a math like
financial problem into a mathematical
problem and when we want to solve this
kind of linear programming using
Mathematica we can easily do like make a
functions and then solve it in one line
I have done this in two ways
so those kind of complex problem can be
used or can be solved using Wolfram and
another area would be okay okay
mean-variance optimization under
uncertainty I think that's a that's the
area emerging often time we do mean very
not like when
invest don't put all the eggs in one
basket kind of principle right so you
have to look at the Rickson return
portion and then try to maximize your
Rick's return ratio and often time we
look at the one set of data and we
maximize and based on that we make
investment decision but whereas this one
we assume data is uncertain we have
thousands of relation of data and when
you have data uncertainty how would you
make investment decisions so that's what
I look at here and I have written some
robust tenancy portfolio some functions
all you have to do is look at the stock
that you want to put in your portfolio
and how many data you are to regenerate
and best on your simulations and
bootstrapping however you like to
regenerate the data and then it gives
you the optimal weights so that's a
that's another area that I think has a
real value one another would be mean
conditional value a tricks optimization
where you major risks not by the
standard deviation but value at risk if
you are measuring your risk using the
value at risk and how can you optimize
your portfolio that's the another area
of application of Wolfram language and
here's a simulation and bootstrapping
and I think Wolfram has a lot of
built-in function that can support
simulation bootstrapping and Finance as
wealth of application especially when it
comes to risk management and data
analytics so we can we can also use
there and here I just run bootstrapping
and then look at the different
descriptive start of that bootstrap data
and then also look at the data on the
histogram and look at the different
property of the data that's another area
that I think this is well there's a well
application of welcome language and
here's a time series part also Wolfram
has a lot of time series functions but
it doesn't have a lot but what I think
is it provides a lot of tools
that you can take to the next level so
mostly the wolfram has a humid air time
series analysis functions but you can
always extend it to a multivariate time
series analysis as well and here I have
some some examples of looking at this
what kind of model would fit to that ear
and looking at the correlation auto
correlations and based on all the
analysis that I have done you can also
forecast the future value of the series
that you are looking at how accurate
that is going to be depends on the
expertise as well as the assumption that
you make on your forecast and here is
one interesting curve that I have been
looking at and it is grabbing attention
whether they'll go they're going to be a
recession very soon right so I look at
the yield curve and the recession and I
look at the data for the last so many
years and you see this is the spike
every time you see the spikes and after
that some time you see the recession and
here is the one I think so I'm not okay
so it doesn't show here but if I can
show you guys big with that here
yes it is just like that and this is
happening so so you see every time this
is volatile in the yellow curve here and
then after some time we see we have
observed in most of the time recession
so right now we are seeing similar
instance and whether the recession will
come or not so anyway the point I'm
making here is yes we can do those kind
of analysis also using the Wolfram
language and this is the last section
and AI and machine learning I think many
of you guys are more expert than nine
but I would like to emphasize here that
we've been talking about this a lot and
most of these companies focus on you
know traditional gold that finance
professors or the business people have
been teaching that is wealth
maximization shareholder wealth
maximization but when you guys work on
this AI and machine learning I would
like to emphasize on broader set of gold
and wealth maximization or money-making
we have enough money then you know we
need and best on the you know the
capitalist idea that we have practiced
over four hundred years now the wealth
is being confronted in the hands of few
people and then more and more people are
left behind right so when you think of
you know machine learning in AI I would
definitely encourage you guys to think
outside the box not just focus on
manipulating data and then making money
think about the environment and the
society and then the equity part what is
it going to do to the people who live in
the society what it is going to do to
the environment and what it is going to
do the planet as a whole
so therefore when I think of this AI and
machine learning I would like to
encourage people to think in a multiple
dimension rather than just focus on the
data data and how the data
kind can be mined and then make money so
we should make a broader objective
broader goal of AI and machine learning
than just making money that's the point
I would like to make and finally as I
said I think I will make this all
available so anybody interested learning
about finance using Wolfram language and
take this to a next level I think most
of you guys are programmers so you can
take the everything that I put here and
you can take to the next level and then
so the people that yes well from is very
powerful and then we can use in the
investment in our system and I was
surprised when I when I came to know
that Wolfram is so powerful but if you
see how many people use in finance
industry not very many people use it and
that surprised me that's that's why I'm
really interested so much built in
knowledge and power but we are not using
it and especially since I'm a faculty
and when I go and teach the students
they don't have math background strong
math background you know like the
companies are so intense we are making
this business education easier easier
easier they come to the class without
much mathematics background math
statistical background and no computer
program at all but if we use Wolfram I
think Wolfram can enhance those skill
help our students and the people to
learn about finance concept using
already built-in knowledge so that's all
I have and I think I'm on time so if you
guys have any question feel free but
again this is more overview than
anything anything specific